- [Instructor] We are
told that triangle ABC,
which is right over here,
is reflected across line l,
so it's reflected across
line l right over here,
to get to triangle A
prime B prime C prime.
Fair enough.
So based on that, they're
going to ask us some questions.
And I encourage you to pause this video
and see if you can figure out
the answers to these questions
on your own before I work through them.
So the first question they say
is well, what's A prime C prime?
This is really what's the length
of segment A prime C prime?
So they want the length
of this right over here.
How do we figure that out?
Well, the key realization
here is a reflection
is a rigid transformation.
Rigid transformation,
which is a very fancy word.
But it's really just saying
that it's a transformation
where the length between
corresponding points don't change.
If we're talking about
a shape like a triangle,
the angle measures won't change,
the perimeter won't change,
and the area won't change.
So we're gonna use the
fact that the length
between corresponding points won't change.
So the length between A prime and C prime
is gonna be the same as
the length between A and C.
So A prime C prime is
going to be equal to AC,
which is equal to they
tell us right over there.
That's this corresponding
side of the triangle.
That has a length of three.
So we answered the first question.
And maybe that gave you a good clue.
And so I encourage you
to keep pausing the video
when you feel like you
can have a go at it.
Alright, the next question is
what is the measure of angle B prime?
So that's this angle right over here.
And we're gonna use the
exact same property.
Angle B prime corresponds to angle B.
It underwent a rigid
transformation of a reflection.
This would also be true
if we had a translation,
or if we had a rotation.
And so right over here, the
measure of angle B prime
would be the same as
the measure of angle B.
But what is that going to be equal to?
Well, we can use the fact
that if we call that measure,
let's just call that X.
X plus 53 degrees, we'll
do it all in degrees,
plus 90 degrees, this right angle here.
Well, the sum of the
interior angles of a triangle
add up to 180 degrees.
And so what do we have?
We could subtract, let's
see, 53 plus 90 is X,
plus 143 degrees is equal to 180 degrees.
And so subtract 143
degrees from both sides.
You will get X is equal to, let's see,
180 minus 40 would be 40.
80 minus 43 would be 37 degrees.
X is equal to 37 degrees,
so that is 37 degrees.
If that's 37 degrees,
then this is also going to be 37 degrees.
Next, they ask us what is
the area of triangle ABC?
ABC.
Well, it's gonna have the same area
as A prime B prime C prime.
And so a couple of ways
we could think about it.
We could try to find the area
of A prime B prime C prime
based on the fact that we already know
that this length is three
and this is a right triangle.
Or we can use the fact that
this length right over here,
four, from A prime to B prime
is gonna be the same thing as
this length right over here,
from A prime to B prime, which is four.
And so the area of this triangle,
especially this is a right triangle,
it's quite straightforward,
it's the base times the height times 1/2.
So this area is gonna be
1/2 times the base, four,
times the height, three,
which is equal to 1/2 of 12,
which is equal to six square units.
And then last but not least,
what's the perimeter of triangle
A prime B prime C prime?
Well, here we just used
the Pythagorean Theorem
to figure out the length
of this hypotenuse.
And we know that this is a length of three
based on the whole rigid transformation
and lengths are preserved.
And so you might immediately recognize
that if you have a right triangle
where one side is three
and the other side is four,
that the hypotenuse is five.
Three four five triangles.
Or you could just the Pythagorean Theorem.
You say three squared plus four squared,
four squared is equal to let's just say
the hypotenuse squared.
Well, three squared plus four
squared, that's nine plus 16.
25 is equal to the hypotenuse squared.
And so the hypotenuse right
over here will be equal to five.
And so they're not asking us
the length of the hypotenuse.
They wanna know the perimeter.
So it's gonna be four
plus three plus five,
which is equal to 12.
The perimeter of either
of those triangles,
because it's just one's
the image of the other
under a rigid transformation.
They're gonna have the same
perimeter, the same area.
The perimeter of either
of the triangles is 12.
The area of either of
the triangles is six.
And we're done.